you
the Audi q7 a heavyweight SUV known for
its comfort and suitability for long
distances but all that weight takes a
toll on sportiness the q7 screams for
more power under the hood
duh suppose and that's what the audi S
q7 is supposed to deliver says our
current estimate is current the SQ seven
is said to be the sportiest and most
powerful version of the SUV but we'll
see whether it's as sporty as it claims
howdy claims that the SQ 7 is more
powerful faster and more comfortable
pressing the gas pedal shows that audi
was serious when it added the s for
sport the twin-turbo v8 diesel and
electric compressor makes the top model
in this series the world's most powerful
diesel SUV then we'll talk montes is
actually surprised at the engine's power
he says you have to be careful with your
foot on the gas pedal or you'll quickly
find yourself exceeding every speed
limit it takes some getting used to but
it's nice to have that power of your
command buzz this option gives us about
any Ted salam the SQ 7 has a newly
developed four liter twin-turbo v8
diesel engine thanks to the electric
compressor used in a car for the first
time here it generates 320 kilowatts at
1,000 rpm it already produces 900 Newton
meters which means strong acceleration
the SQ 7 Sprint's from 0 to 100
kilometers an hour just 4.8 seconds the
objects like women howdy developer
Stefan Lawrence says the car has to
conventional turbochargers when the revs
are still in the lower range and less
air is provided the electric condensers
support the system providing more air
intake and that means acceleration
little has changed in the exterior of
the audi S q7 the striking front and
aluminum mirror caps are standard in
Audis S models the rear is dominated by
four tailpipes
the high quality interior is not only a
joy to behold it is also very intuitive
to use the electric seats offer good
lateral support another highlight the
built-in role stabilizers which prevent
the car from tilting when accelerating
in curves
the AMA the only spokesman says the SQ 7
has an actuator on each axle replacing
the conventional stabilizers the front
actuator exerts up to 1,200 Newton
meters and the rear one up to 1000
Newton meters of counter torque against
the vehicles body roll normally if you
speed into a curve lateral acceleration
makes the car wobble this systems
counter force keeps the car horizontally
aligned sounds like golf ball isn't yet
the new audi S q7 is available with five
or seven seats the optional third row of
seats can be raised or lowered
electrically 24 assists systems help
keep this 5.07 meter giant on the road
montes was initially skeptical whether
the SQ 7 would fulfill all its promises
but after driving it for a while he's
convinced on all points the handling is
very sporty has a very powerful engine
and gives the driver a great sense of
control so Martha says the whole package
is well-rounded and solid of course it
isn't low priced but then it does have a
top range engine and plenty of extras
you won't find in other vehicles multi
top model is Iran and Manhattan their
feel extras he's an unknown fatso and
even gonna keep
SUVs are still selling like hotcakes say
hot wanted to profit from the hype
around off-road vehicles so even before
the Spanish company could launch its
first true SUV on to the market it
unveiled the Leon experience which has
the aura of an SUV on the basis of a
normal station wagon
yes the other car test of I know Dyson
over displays the cars big rear hatch it
has all-wheel drive so that even when
fully loaded and on slippery ground and
still reaches its destination with under
ride protection front and rear it has a
real outdoor feeling but do you need
that muslimah though the experience also
comes in a gasoline and a diesel
front-wheel drive version the all-wheel
versions make sense if you regularly
drive off road or uh none paved roads if
you only drive in the city and on the
highway you probably don't need it we
tested a version with the all-wheel for
dr + 110 kilowatts of power
this version is manually shifted the DSG
gearbox comes only in the versions with
the most powerful engines Donald says
the st experience not only has lots of
trunk space the interior is roomy to the
standard sport seats provide good
lateral support and are comfortable even
on long trips his tip on options is to
get the + navigation system it has a
larger screen and connects easily with
your smartphone in the interior the
large round instruments are uncluttered
the design is sporting not stayed
interior characteristics specific to
this model include orange decorative
stitching on the steering wheel and the
ex perience logo the seat design is also
exclusive to the experience
the design of the experience is as
sporty as every other Leon the lower
part of the car with its unpainted
plastic parts makes a much more robust
impression than in cars with lacquered
bumpers
the sleek rear displays the experience
badge with its orange X the off-road
looked down below encourages a lacks
approach to washing after all a bit of
dirt and grit announce off-road
experience
I know says you don't always need an SUV
when there are station wagons with
all-wheel drive and an off-road look
that saves weight and makes the car more
agile the sea Utley on st experience is
sporty-er than a VW Golf all track and
cost much less than an audi a4 allroad
and if you want to save even more get a
leon st with all-wheel drive and do
without the off-road look if the styling
in the leon st is good enough for you
you can get all wheel drive and a 110
kilowatt diesel engine for 2,000 euros
less if you like it sporty-er you can
choose the fr version with the same
power but then there is little price
advantage over the experience
the classic VW beetle has been tweaked
yet again to conform to the latest
automobile trends the new dune model has
a robust look thanks to a wider body and
silver under bodyguard the ride height
has been raised 10 millimeters 18-inch
alloy wheels complete the new look the
VW dune engines have an output of
between 77 and 162 kilowatts in Germany
the VW dune is a starting price of just
under twenty-four thousand euros the
Porsche Cayman like the Porsche Boxster
before is to join the 718 series the
came and six-cylinder aspiration engine
will be replaced by a turbocharged
four-cylinder engine and the 718 Cayman
S the 2.5 liter engine generates 257
kilowatts of power and for the first
time ever the Cayman will cost less than
the Boxster and Germany it is available
for just over 64,000 euros
I'm going down to our man Emmanuel
Schaefer says when Toyota brought out
the first generation rave for 1994 it
basically launched the crossover SUV
segment as we know it today rave
incidentally stands for recreational
activity vehicle I said activating
customers buying the rave for can now
choose between a hybrid or non hybrid
version the option of an additional
electric motor is part of the new
overhaul the toyota rav4 has undergone a
facelift quite literally the front now
looks very different the nose has been
reshaped and the front grille slimmed
down for a look that is altogether more
sleek the room for utilizes Toyota's
Hybrid Synergy Drive that powers the
prius and other semi electric models and
the brand's lineup and comes with a 2.5
liter normally aspirated gasoline engine
assisted by an electric motor now
tried-and-tested technology at Toyota
manwa says the addition of Toyotas
hybrid drive is probably the most
important update in the new generation
rave or you can choose between options
either front drive where the electric
motor is installed at the front as with
a normal gasoline engine or all-wheel
drive where the electric motor is fitted
in the rear driving the rear axle and
doing away with the transfer case and
cardan shaft the all-wheel drive version
costs an extra three thousand euros
Alexa one thing this Toyota isn't is
speedy 180 km/h is the top speed another
chance to save fuel and reduce your co2
emissions which is probably more
important for customers who care about
the environment and opted for a hybrid
that's light emmanuel says the 2.5 liter
gasoline engine and electric motor
produce a combined output of 145
kilowatts or 197 horsepower the car
takes just over eight seconds to reach
100 km/h that's quite respectable
considering it weighs at least 17
hundred kilos when empty and according
to the manufacturer only uses five
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers
in the interior Toyota has added more
soft touch surfaces the steering wheel
is new there are new onboard features
and a 7-inch screen for the multimedia
system passengers also get to enjoy the
ride the rave 4 has one of the most
spacious cabins in the class
the trunk offers an impressive 547
litres of space or 501 leaders in this
hybrid version the additional electric
motor also increases the overall weight
to 1.7 tons but those are the only
differences
let's keep fit enough there are three
different drive versions for the rave
for first of all the hybrid version that
we're testing then there's the two liter
gasoline had a two liter diesel engine
but anyone wanting all-wheel drive will
have to go for the hybrid version
because I like the previous generation
you can no longer combine the diesel
with all-wheel drive and automatic
transmission toyota is hoping that sixty
percent of customers will opt for the
hybrid a plus for the environment my
thoughts it the manuals take on the
fourth generation of the toyota rav4 the
overall concept makes a lot of sense it
drives well and as a hybrid is even
relatively green but he has two small
criticisms first he finds the choice of
dry version somewhat limited and second
the lack of visibility to the rear the D
pillar is very broad which diminishes
the driver's rear view right on target
of info I [ __ ] and resist follow on
there's almost summers just around the
corner says our car tested michelle
austyn maha and it's time to do some
gardening so she needs a spacious car to
get supplies like I mercedes vito
Dean vine here michelle says this van is
used for all kinds of purposes be it as
a family ride or a builder's van used
for carrying tools or even for a courier
service of all vehicles vans are
designed to be the most versatile
drivers will come to expect different
things depending on what they want to
use the veto for our test vehicle is a
box van it's mainly used by courier
services or workmen needing to transport
tools as a courier van the veto has to
cover many kilometers but it still needs
to be suitable for other purposes to
you know ends up Eliza shell says the
veto has to meet many different needs
depending on what it's used for but all
drivers agree that safety is a crucial
feature and that's something Mercedes
attaches great importance to as well the
veto comes with collision prevention
assist blind spot assist and Lane
Keeping Assist only self-driving is not
an option yet our test model Vito has
100 kilowatts of power with a price of
forty 4898 euros in Germany the base
model is already available at around 36
thousand euros
God Addison Michelle expected this big
bulky van to be cumbersome to drive and
have poor visibility but that wasn't the
case she says the rearview camera even
makes reverse parking fun mystics boss
michelle has now arrived at the garden
center to collect supplies she doesn't
have to worry about cargo space the veto
has a load volume of 5.8 cubic meters
the veto box van has a wheelbase of 3.2
meters
thanks to the rear row of seats up to
five people can fit into the van
passenger cabin and trunk are separated
by a glass window and behind that
there's plenty of stowage space so
Michelle could buy as much as she likes
the Vans interior is minimalist and very
practical
here you won't find the gear stick on
the center console however instead
there's a gear level on the
multi-purpose steering wheel michelle
has now completed her shopping tour and
is pleased with what she got but she
managed to be pretty restrained in the
end she could have fitted up to 1.3 tons
of cargo into that van
how God knows Michelle was pleased she
just about managed to fit her purchase
into the van now she's ready for summer
it has the grace of a benigni sculpture
and contours that could have been carved
by Michelangelo the bits are any 5300 GT
has classic Italian styling written all
over it but for its actual creator this
sports car wasn't just about its
captivating looks it bears the hallmark
of Giotto bit cerini arguably the most
talented racing car constructor of the
1960s the 5300 gt's mission was to leave
the competition in the dust on the
racetrack and fill its creator with
pride it's Erini the very name still
makes Ferrari or Maserati owners nervous
it's maker had high hopes of it becoming
the new star on the sports car horizon
following triumphs on the track but this
supernova on four wheels fizzled out all
too rapidly today most people wouldn't
even recognize a 5,300 GT Eric Oswald is
the happy owner of one of these rare
racers the 5300 GT was built between
1964 and 68 in a limited edition
according to some sources production
amounted to just 70 and assembled
specimens
giotto bit cirini was born in Livorno in
1926 he is considered one of the most
influential constructors in the history
of motorsports he spent five years at
Ferrari as developer designer test
driver and chief engineer among his
accomplishments there the iconic GTL
eventually there was a clash of egos
between him and boss Enzo Ferrari
leading to his departure
the GTO went on to clock up a string of
victories and remains one of the most
viable and hotly desired racing cars of
all time for some people the greatest
Ferrari ever models have been auctioned
for up to 30 million dollars only 39
were built
back to Giotto pizza weenie after being
recruited by Renzo revolta he created
the eso grief Oh a high-performance gran
turismo with American engineering on
board
but bit cerini wanted more he built a
two-seater competition car based on the
grief oh his boss revolta wanted to sell
cars rather than burn money on the
racetrack however the two likewise
parted ways bit Serena took his latest
creation with him and named it the bits
arena 5300 GT the v8 engine was like
that in the grief Oh taken from the
Chevrolet Corvette
until anybody did cerini was the first
to come up with a front mid-engine
explains proud owner Eric engines on top
of the axle have a far higher center of
gravity an engine below and behind the
axle is far lower which gives you a
massive advantage in terms of handling
it's still copied today nothing for
texts read off what is the old computer
it Selena would follow from the very
start of his career when he was making
bigger cars been Cellini had a
preference for high-capacity American
engines over their smaller high powered
Italian rivals he also once tried to
convince Ferrari to construct a large
displacement engine with lower rev
levels dr. training athletes articles
through the 5.4 liter v8 complemented by
a battery of twin Weber carburetors
pumps out 360 horsepower and that's in
the basic version
the engine is unusually far back the
only access to the distributor cap was
via an opening on the dashboard
take to the wheel of a bit cirini and
you're left in no doubt that it was
constructed for the track the
full-blooded v8 propelling a two-seater
weighing just eleven hundred kilos
delivers the kind of ferociousness
otherwise associated with modern super
sports cars the GT is not meant for a
jaunt in the countryside
the 5300 GT was launched into action on
the track against Ferrari to give bits
of any revenge for his dismissal by his
former employer and he did win a few
times at the one thousand kilometer race
at Monza 1965 for example the 5300 GT
left all the GTOs in its tracks but the
car maker was unable to follow up on
that success not least because of a lack
of funds
Eric Oswald's prized beauty is the first
of just 10 corza editions featuring a
lightweight body
until he needs bit cerini went with this
car which previously had an aluminum
body to a boat constructor in Italy
together they build a fiberglass body
it's irini then made nine more courses
about hot on da no no invite three
course I'll skip out
today the 5300 GT is a member of a very
exclusive club anyone who owns one will
be desperate to hold on to it potential
buyers are looking at a six-figure price
tag whatever condition it's in most
recently a 5,300 GT changed hands for
over half a million euros for the vast
majority of ATO aficionados a bit cerini
will always be just a dream
you